[Music]
well it is a good name for it yeah if
it's about BuzzFeed running out of lists
BuzzFeed running out of lists it's a
good good name for I think so too
yeah I couldn't agree more on the list
of the best possible names for this
piece on BuzzFeed I would be number one
should be number one yeah you'll see
what I mean
all right here are some buzz buzz fits
buzz because this table Jesus Christ
chin and I eat you uh Jesus all right
here we go
here are some BuzzFeed lists I saw
recently that I thought were a little
weak and I'm gonna be frank with you I
thought these were a little weak and
that's why I wanted to show them on the
page for example this is a weak list
check this one out 17 times they chose
the wrong font I thought that's a fun
receptive Airy bad but I don't think
that was good look at this one 15
kangaroos who don't know whether to
fight you or make love to you oh boy I'm
gonna choose the latter that is a sexy
kangaroo yeah look at this one right
here seven times a bullhorn wasn't
telling look at this one twelve dogs who
watch the house being ransacked and
didn't do jack [ __ ]
it's actually - in the garage you have
insurance yeah look at this 190 photos
of Chris Hemsworth peeking out of a
toilet that's a surprise yeah 27 tinder
profiles were pretty sure I just
purchased faces painted on a hard-boiled
egg I waited pic click on that 16 times
the Amazon packaging department overdid
it I look at this one one professional
wrestler who goes by the name Gargant
you won that's a list of one yeah for
this one 17 rejected Marlboro Man and
there's this one 24 elite Coffee
Roasters who know their career is
[ __ ] I like this one which Kenny
Rogers cosmetic surgery procedure are
you I forgot he was here tonight 21
candid photos of Senator Ted Cruz in his
natural gelatinous state Wow and finally
26 things your boyfriend put his junk on
when you weren't home
we've all got it down
you